hey guys what's up this is andrew from
jensens.com
so for those who are watching my video
for the first time very quickly let me
introduce myself
i used to work as a professional trader
for six years
and i just resigned one week ago
and actually last friday yesterday was
my
last day so next week guys i'm gonna be
able to be here with you
every day to do updates for your perfect
stocks
like amc or gamestop and then the week
after guys i'm going to
on holidays to see my family so it's
going to be a bit tougher
but i'm still going to give you some
updates so today i want to make a huge
update guys on
amc let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so as usual let's start
on the forest time frame
and let me remind you what i was telling
you
in my last video so we were
here uh developing in a triangle
that was labeled as my fourth wave of
this
five waves development that started at
eight guys on the 10th of may all the
way up i told you guys
the levels where we're gonna have some
reactions i told you roughly how long
would be the consolidation
i was just using you know uh what i like
to use which is idiot wave theory
trend lines divergences all these kind
of indicators that
for me helped me to actually choose my
preferred scenario
so in my last video i was spotting here
a triangle guys so
a b c d e i showed you guys
in the idiot wave you know book that i
always keep here with me
what is a triangle sorry i guess so
these are all the types of triangles
that you can have
it can be ascending descending
converging or expanding
all right and here we have a converging
triangle
that is making five waves here and i
told you that
if we break out here so let's zoom in
guys let's go into our little frame
if we break out here it means that this
triangle
is over that the fourth wave is complete
and that we are starting the fifth wave
i also told you guys and i was quite
accurate here that we are going to
correct 252 guys all right
so 52 i found it using different methods
so
i encourage you guys to go and watch the
video i published
just before this one because it's
actually very interesting to see you
know when
some methods work the reasons why they
worked and
so that we keep using this and here i
was using
fibonacci retracements i was using trend
lines
and i was using uh this breakout so
i found that we are going to bounce back
around the 51 50 to
52 levels guys so basically we went here
to 51.87
first and the second time we retested it
at 51.69
so very close actually to my levels
and then as expected we bounced back for
now
everything looks perfect and we bounce
back
and for me we are starting the third
wave
so now i'm gonna break down this video
in uh two
steps the first step uh we are gonna
analyze the facts
what we are having and then we are gonna
use this and try to combine it with what
we know
and build different scenarios and select
the preferred one
so as usual guys i'm gonna give you my
view in this video
so the first thing we're having so i've
been telling you guys this
for actually more than one month that
this
50 period moving average on the hourly
time frame is actually
the one that is giving us the best uh
reactions
all right so you can go and check in the
past it was giving us
very nice reactions all the way up then
here when you got broken
we had this strong move down and then he
we broke it uh on the upside again
so you know it it's working for a very
long time that's what
is good about spotting something that is
working you can keep
using it all right and it's never going
to be the same thing that you're going
to use on different stocks
or even on the same stock but at
different time
you know when something is working it's
usually working for some time and then
suddenly it's not working anymore and
you need to switch to what is working
again
so here this is working as i'm giving
you this when it's not gonna work
anymore we're gonna see it and i'm gonna
tell you that it's not what we need to
look at
anymore for now this is what is working
the best and look here
so we broke it we break it on the upside
then
let me even zoom in a bit more guys
because right now i have more time so
i'm making you know
shorter term analysis with you i'm going
to make another update
on monday's closed guys and on tuesdays
close again
i have now more time even if my contract
is not finished you know
i'm right now in this period where you
know that we call the garden leave
so basically i'm still under like my
contract is not finished yet
but i don't need to go to work so i have
more time
so i need to stay on the hourly
timeframe
all right and you can see so we break it
we retest it
guys so i told you go check my other
video as well this was one of the reason
i told you 51.52 guys is because i had
this moving average here and it
acted perfectly as support as we
expected
and so we have one two three four
candles five candles then we have the
rebound
and here guys i mean you know this was
an easy trade you know if you do some
scalping of course you know amc is not
the best stock to do scalping but it's
just an example you can
lock easily some small profits but with
a very high probability
of being right and then here look i have
an example of
a fake out so it's very interesting to
look at
because you know even when something is
working very well the market is still
gonna make
some tricks so here this breakout you
know is not perfect
but you can see that on the hourly
timeframe we close below
one time just a little bit but you know
theoretically
it's enough then a second candle below
again
and then we have this strong rebound so
here it is what we call a fake out
so fake outs are actually very tricky
and if you use this moving average as a
stop loss
here you would have stopped your
position all right that's true now
let me show you guys and i'm going to
talk about it in the course that i'm
building right now guys
it's going to be in few chapters there
is one chapter on breakouts and i'm
explaining
you guys exactly how to play breakouts
and how to avoid
fake outs and one of the thing you
absolutely
need to look at is the volume and
if your breakout occurs with small
volumes compared to the volumes you're
having
you know in the same period then this is
likely to be a fake out and here look
the volumes we have
so it was 17th of june 11 the time stamp
all right
look at my screen like on the downside
so i'm gonna find the associated volume
guys
it's this one right so basically there
is no volume even here
okay let's say this is not the breakout
the breakout is here
you can see at 12 what is the volume
here
at 12 guys it's zero zero
volume so basically this fakeout is a
fakeout because it occurred with
zero volume so if you are trading this
you can't consider this as a breakout
so just here i'm giving you some tips on
how to avoid the tricks the market is
making to
us every day so then we go higher
and we come back here and we close the
week with a bit of weakness that's true
but guys look at the market the s p 500
was down
i think 1.5 nasdaq down as well all the
european market got destroyed
so actually amc hold very well compared
to the other stocks so here
i think that even if we had some
weakness this is still looking good
we are still trading above this 50
period moving average undoubtedly time
frame that is for me very important so
this is one fact then second fact
that i need to show you guys i told you
that
here we would go down you remember why
guys because
i told you we have a divergence all
right market going
higher so we had this divergence on the
30 minutes time frame
all right so let me show you this again
here market making new highs
and the macd making lower highs all
right you remember
and this was under 30 minutes time frame
so i told you that on the 30 minutes
time frame we have a divergence but we
don't have it on the hourly so we're
gonna have a
small move down and then rebound this is
what happened now
if i go back on the hourly timeframe i
have here something guys that i want to
show you
is that we have an exaggerated bearish
divergence right
so this is one more fact that i need to
show you so basically market
making flat basically so going to the
same level it
traded on the 15th of june around 64.65
and during this time the macd is
actually making
lower highs and this is true on the
hourly timeframe and it's also true on
the forest time frame
you can see that here the macd is making
low sorry maybe you don't see
the max is making lower highs on the
four hours
and on the hourly so once again let me
show you this guys
this is this one okay
so market making a flat move
with the momentum indicator decreasing
so basically we're losing steam and the
market is not able
to actually make a new high so you can
see that here usually we should make a
new high
with more momentum this is what happens
during moves up but we
fail you know we go higher but we i mean
not higher at the same level
but with less energy so it's almost the
same as the regular divergence
it's a bit less powerful because here
the market is making new highs
this is really you know diverging market
making high highs
magazine making low highs here is being
flat and the maxi decreasing
but it's still a bearish divergence all
right even if it's less powerful so we
need to take in
into account and now we're having it on
the hourly time frame so
it's gonna affect the price action a bit
longer
than the one we had on the 30 minutes
time frame so this is a second fact
now the third fact i want to talk about
and i showed you guys this
in my previous video as well is that
this first
wave here is perfectly broken down
into five waves and is respecting very
well
the idiot wave theory which is saying
that when the third wave is extended
then the first wave is usually equal to
the fifth wave
so let me show you guys this as well i
know i'm repeating a bit
things but it's very good for you guys
to see this many times
it was this example so i told you that
when the third wave is extended
so here we have different scenarios with
different ratios this is
elliot wave book guys you can find it on
google
just type you know idiot wave principle
first and pressure pdf
and it's the third link it's this one so
here it's saying that when the third
wave is extended one two three four five
you have five waves inside the third
wave
then wave one is equal to a5 in terms of
length all right and you can have a look
at this i'm not gonna go through this
here with you guys because this is not
what we're having and
you can you know use these ratios as
well if you
see these scenarios happening so here my
facts
are i repeat we have the triangle we
broke out on the upside doing
five waves we broke the 50 period moving
average on the abolition frame that was
the resistance we are perfectly
supported by it and we close
above it during the week we have a fake
out with very low volume so we could
avoid it very
easily if we know how to tread breakouts
we have this our first abc corrective
pattern
and then here we are doing the third
wave
so in the third wave we are just
breaking down uh
you know those two first moves into one
two so right now my preferred scenario
guys
is that on monday we're having a very
strong move up and we're starting the
third wave we should
start the third wave this is what should
happen but once again we're having this
sneaky
exaggerated divergence that might cause
some troubles i have an
alternative scenario so once again this
is my preferred scenario
but i have an alternative scenario where
actually here
we're making an abc here it's basically
a combination of corrective patterns
you know that is consolidating usually
doing a sideways correction
and here we might have another you know
kind of
abc so this is an alternative scenario
and this is possible as well and then
this would be the one
two and then
of course three four five so this is
possible as well
and to know how deep we could go we can
use
again retracements and you can see that
here we have plenty of room guys because
during this impulsive moves the second
wave usually retraces to 50 or 61.8
percent
so we went to the 50 level that i told
you guys 52
but we might also go to the 61.8
retracement level which is around 48 and
we have on the hourly timeframe the 200
period moving average coming here
so this would be an alternative scenario
that could still
be valid that would still not invalidate
my longer term analysis that is saying
that we go to 135
in this fifth wave i'm just wondering if
the second wave is complete
or not and once again this exaggerated
divergence for me
is not strong enough signal i mean
indication
to tell me that my preferred scenario is
changing so my preferred scenario i
remind you guys is still the same one
so we're making here one we finished the
two and this is a one two in the third
wave
so i don't think this would happen i
think we're gonna have a bullish monday
so let's see let's see so that's it for
me i hope you enjoyed this video and if
you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys